o crear empleo el día número 78 de la
guerra que empezó hace más de dos meses
una guerra que viene sufriendo este país
en las últimas horas se han producido
diversos ataques en las regiones de
schumi chernigov en el norte del país
aunque también en mi pro al menos una
persona ha fallecido como consecuencia
de un ataque contra una planta eléctrica
en la región de donbass es donde se
están verificando los enfrentamientos
más cruentos entre las tropas ucranianas
y las rusas así la localidad de
severodonezk ya que se encuentra en
riesgo de sufrir una grave asedio por
parte de las fuerzas rusas ha suspendido
en las últimas horas las evacuaciones
una señal de que la situación de
seguridad ha empeorado sustancialmente
en este contexto el país también vive
una crisis humanitaria que se está
agudizando día tras día esta mañana nos
hemos despertado aquí en jarquín donde
estamos con larguísimas colas de
personas que están intentando abastece
abastecerse de bienes primarios como
comida y también gasolina aún viene que
está escaseando en este país en lo cual
también está dificultando la labor de
las organizaciones humanitarias que
están en el terreno en él de ayudar a la
población local